jeffrey epstein had an international
sex trafficking scheme gelade maxwell
this moneyed
social girl she was the one who
would satisfy his every whim glenn
maxwell's charged with enticement of
minors
sex trafficking of children and perjury
epstein's girlfriend galen maxwell
helped connect him to the wealthy and
famous
she gave him a veneer of respectability
she always struck me as very confident
full of life
but she's obviously a good actress
because there was this whole other
world going on the family lived at this
grand country estate
they had huge parties i remember meeting
galain and i just thought wow this girl
is
really fun how on earth
could she have got to this place she
said no they're not young girls they're
children
you can see tiny pin holes on the wall
and that's where the cameras were
killing maxwell and jeffrey epstein are
untouchable until it all came crashing
down around them
then jeffrey epstein was found dead in
his jail cell
jolane maxwell disappeared so who is the
girl
beneath all of this
well there's no more epstein glenn
maxwell was now front and center
she inherited jeffrey epstein's secrets
this is a bigger animal than anyone
knows
and glenn maxwell has the answers
you